foxes alert authorities set to give an
update on the new york city subway
shooting at any moment as we get brand
new details on what happened right now a
large-scale manhunt still underway for
the gunman who unleashed horror this
morning during rush hour commute the
suspect who was described as a black
male wearing a gas mask and a green
construction type vest set off a smoke
bomb and opened fire on a crowded subway
train 28 people are injured including 10
who suffered gunshot wounds brian yennis
is on the scene with the latest on the
investigation and brian you got there
this morning during america's newsroom
you're immediately there what have you
learned since then catch us up
dana they have now found a u-haul van
that the nypd has been searching for all
afternoon i believe we have live
video of this van this is a van with
arizona plate al3
i believe let me just verify that but
this is the actual u-haul van that was
sent out on a bolo this is a beyond the
lookout alert that was sent out to the
nypd in connection with this shooting we
have no idea what the connection was but
we do know that the nypd was warned to
take extreme precautions
if and when they did encounter this
u-haul van so this is good news that
they have at least found this van
right now we know that they are looking
for a five foot five black male about
180 pounds heavy set somebody who was
wearing a green construction vest and a
gray sweatshirt they have not released a
photo of this man all day but we do know
only about that u-haul van that
apparently they have now found
earlier today just before 8 30 this
morning a man
suspect wearing a gas mask
set off a gas canister on the n train as
it was making its way into the 36th
street subway station he then opened
fire on the train as well as the
platform wounding at least 10 people
five in critical condition another 18
suffering injuries like smoke inhalation
amazingly everyone is expected to
survive we're told the gun jammed which
probably spared some lives the wounded
there were also treated
on the platform by fellow new yorkers
who sprung into action to help as first
responders made their way here is one
eyewitness
there was
three people who
were just profusely bleeding everywhere
like just just pools of blood everywhere
um one woman was she had a shoulder
injury that wasn't bleeding but it
looked like it could have been like a
night wound or something like it was
just a very bad
bruise
this is video from inside the subway car
you can see there's an individual in
between the cars one with smoke one
without we don't know if it's the
shooter but people were trying to make
their way out of that chaos as they saw
one of their train cars filling up with
smoke we also heard from mayor eric
adams who says one of the cameras one of
the security cameras in that train
station was malfunctioning during all of
this in fact it could be the case that
all of the cameras at the train station
malfunctioned during all of this which
is why we didn't have an image of this
guy we are told police were able to get
an image of this guy through an image
from a cell phone video that was taken
by a bystander here is mayor eric adams
from earlier today
we would not allow new yorkers to be
terrorized even by a single individual
nypd is searching for the suspect at
large and we will find him
extended ammo magazines were found as
well as this bag containing fireworks
and gas canisters and as well as smoke
bombs according to the new york post
which obtained that photo we are
awaiting a press conference at any
moment at this point but we do know that
they have found that van and that is
that is a big step in this investigation
brian a few of us have questions i want
to ask you one is it um
you showed some of the items that they
found there has been some reporting that
there was also a hatchet is that true
yeah i have not been able to confirm
that but i know that the new york post
is reporting that a hatchet was among
the other items that was found in that
bag
and we'll take it around the
table here jesse
hey brian
is this a an asian neighborhood where
this subway stop was located some of the
victims looked asian uh to me and have
any law enforcement sources told you
that there could be a possible hate
crime angle here
yeah they at this moment this is an
asian neighborhood about 35 of the
population is asian the other is
hispanic so it is a hispanic asian
neighborhood
the nypd commissioner said today that
there was no nexus to terrorism as of
now they haven't been able they're not
ruling anything out and they also
mentioned that there was no um
focus on an ethnic group or a hate crime
essentially that this person from what
they believe was not searching for
specifically asians and of course that
that matters because we've been seeing a
surge in hate crimes particularly
against asians here in new york city
judging
brian you know when you when you
reference the uh the u-haul
how far was it from the station
it's a great question it's about uh
about i would say i think it was about
five to ten miles away based on my
google here but it's about a half hour
drive away towards coney island so we
are in uh in sunset park and you would
continue to drive sort of south uh
towards uh the water there in brooklyn
okay and would i be correct in assuming
that everyone has already checked out uh
who was the last person to rent that
u-haul
one would imagine that is the first
thing that they did um i would imagine
that they would check for that as well
as uh perhaps the you know any prints
that they may have found on a gun uh
there's been a conflicting reports on
the type of gun um it's been reported
that it's been it was a glock
semi-automatic that's not something
we've been able to independently confirm
but we do know that there were extended
ammo magazines that were found on the
scene as well
harold ford jr brian uh real quick brian
thanks for your reporting
have they confirmed there was only one
person i think i've heard city officials
including the mayor talk about an
individual has that been confirmed yet
or is that still an open question
there has not been any indication at all
that they're looking for more than one
individual but i will say that when they
sent out the bolo the be on the lookout
for the u-haul a part of that alert was
to be careful for whom whoever could be
in that in that vehicle so um you know i
i there hasn't been any indication at
all that this was some sort of
effort by two or more individuals
everything that we've heard has been
full concentration on this one suspect
who we have yet to see a photo of
which is pretty remarkable uh given
everything and also pretty remarkable
that we have no idea how this person
managed
to get out we do know that an r train
moved into the next station remarkably
when everybody was wounded at that 36th
street station mta employees sprung into
action and they moved wounded they moved
wounded people into an r train that then
moved one station over and they were
able to get help there
i don't know in that chaos perhaps this
guy was able to get out obviously with
the smoke and everything but
that's what we know right now an
individual is the center of the focus of
this
go ahead clearly brian given given the
location of the u-haul and with all of
the cameras on the streets they should
be able to
intersect or at least cross-reference
and go backwards as to where that u-haul
came from and that cross-referencing all
the cameras and the iphones they will
definitely be able to identify where he
got into the van but that's what i
believe i mean i have confidence that
he's going to be found
i would imagine that that bolo that was
sent out this afternoon from what i saw
was sent out about two o'clock maybe it
was sent out earlier but between that
and then finding it one would imagine
that this was a huge clue for them to
search those traffic cameras to be able
to find its location so close to this
train station right all right brian
yenis thank you we are awaiting this
press conference i know you'll be
covering it there so we might check in
with you before the hour is up greg
it is
a shocking situation we talked about i
was thinking about how long you and i
have been doing this show together and
we remember we kept talking about soft
targets like this yeah and it's just
it's a horrible thing that that happened
and to know that the cameras weren't
working that is
absolutely
absolutely infuriating when you think
about
how much money this city sits on how
much taxes they have where the money
goes we know a billion dollars
disappeared
in a fund for the homeless and they
don't even have these cameras working
when you need a most uh the probably the
and there was this a very new york thing
when you watched that initial video
where people were just
uh very very leisurely get getting up
and moving except for one guy he was
just sitting there because he had his
earbuds in and he had his head down
everybody essentially riding the subway
these days is deliberately oblivious
right it's it's obliviousness by choice
because it's to avoid flashers
crazy violent panhandlers and now you
have this it's it's it reminds me i
probably said this before that like when
you were a kid and you watched old
batman and you you had this idea of like
the city being this crazy place with
these weird little villains and stuff i
never thought that that would actually
happen but this is an anomaly i mean
it's uh it we we
we're in the midst of a crime wave
that's pretty ugly and the subways are
disgusting the streets are depressing
but this is a no this is an anomaly this
i don't know why you can't call this a
terrorist act it is an act of terror i
guess well judge let me ask you that is
that
motive
that you have to is that why they're
reluctant to say you know what's
interesting about it is
motive is something that prosecutors and
police really don't care a hell of a lot
about the motive is not as relevant as
as whether or not an individual
committed a crime it becomes relevant
and i i fought for a hate crimes law in
new york and a federal one as well
because there should be an added
punishment when you select a victim
based out of hate but i think that for
them to have said right from the get-go
this wasn't terrorist uh terrorism i
thought was very unusual but you know
what i think is interesting about this
just when the city is getting ready for
the summer just when people are saying
you know the city's coming back now we
have this situation uh uh you know on a
train we've had stabbings on the train
we've got people being shoved in front
of trains you know from a macro level um
you know this this is the kind of thing
that will continue to happen until
we get albany and the democrats to start
putting people in jail and recognizing
that there are people who are danger to
a community
now people can say you know i don't know
who this individual is but this is a guy
who planned it he calculated it he knew
exactly when to throw off the canisters
when to shoot so he wouldn't be caught
in the tunnel and it creates the
ultimate fear and and mass casualties
and people feel incredibly vulnerable in
the city right now people are afraid and
it's underground think about that i mean
it's just mass hysteria that one person
can create and harold he chose to
attack during rush hour and this is at a
time when the city is trying to get back
to work right people are coming back to
the city they have to come in maybe it's
five days a week but for some it's just
a hybrid work schedule right it's a
tuesday that's usually a day when people
would come into the city and this will
certainly
make people think twice about that
there's also you know people put their
children on the subway to get to their
schools
so
i agree every everything you've said is
just is exactly right i would i would
differ a little bit from the judge but i
agree with you in one huge respect
politicians oftentimes will talk about
crime and they'll talk about numbers to
try to say when things are improving or
things are worsening to make a case for
whatever it is they want to make a case
for
but you can't fight psychology and to
your point there's a huge psychology
that things are not getting better and
that things are worsening and this
morning this incident is only going to
make people think uh even worse about uh
everything from how their kids get to
school to how they get to work
and frankly how you're able to get to
your kids if something was to go wrong
or how are you able to get anywhere in
the city if something is to go wrong i
think the politics of it will take care
of itself i also think
i'm really curious and i'm i'm prayerful
that this was just an individual and
this was not some coordinated a lot of
stuff he had there was a all the
pictures we're seeing and if he was five
foot five the dimensions they gave us of
of this man
it it seems
likely that he could have had help to do
this and unlikely he could have done
this done this alone and if he did do it
alone judge i would refer to you it
seemed to me that there had to be more
of a planning aspect to this
than just as some may have speculated i
thought you and bill did a really good
job this morning talking about it he
just said it appears he may not have
just awakened and said i'm gonna go do
this because i'm disgruntled i hope that
is the case in this don't get me wrong i
wish the tragedy did not happen but i
hope if it in light of what we know i
hope he did it alone which is why what
inspired my question to brian there at
the very end that's what the worst
combination is always evil in planning
we still have no idea what went down in
in
vegas
right right you know and and pla and
planning
reflects an intelligence that it could
be often it resulted in more devastating
effects than random crime because it
because it does know how to target the
vulnerabilities which is what we saw
with vegas and in this case that's
somebody thinking this thing through
makes them purely evil there's no
question carol i don't know that we
disagree at all
i don't want to talk about the politics
of biting and all that kind of stuff
that's all i didn't even mention biden
what i'm talking about is the fact that
we've got so much crime in new york this
doesn't help new york come back i agree
100 okay and but there was a level of
planning there's a level of capability
there was a level of you know
pre-planning how do you get these gas
canisters how do you get those and by
the way if you have a 380 with an
extended uh
magazine how come you don't have like a
nine millimeter how come you don't have
an ar-15 you know why was he limited to
the 380 what's going on here
maybe it was just one person jesse
listen to mayor eric adams on the
terrorism point here
this is terror
of someone attempted to terrorize our
system uh they brought in what appears
to be some form of smoke device uh they
discharged a weapon and so um i don't
want to be premature and identifying if
this was was not i think at this time
the investigators are going to do their
due diligence to properly identify what
happened here and so i think at this
time it's premature to state um exactly
what happened here still new we're still
unfolding the investigation i appreciate
the caution
while they try to figure out what's
behind all of it he has coveted and
looks ridiculous managing this shooting
spree from quarantine from his apartment
come on put a mask on get outside and
manage the crisis it's okay
um
i understand what he's saying because
people think tara they think muslim they
think jihadist and we get that but
i guess technically when you're doing
some sort of mass shooting like yes it's
terrorizing the population but when he
says the word it makes new yorkers think
oh my god and it brings you back to 9
11. so he says that right and then the
governor comes out and she says no
terror
and then the police chief comes out and
she says
no terror but we're not ruling terror
out so new yorkers are thinking
what do we got here we have one mayor in
quarantine yeah the governor shows up
out of nowhere and then the police chief
says we don't know what's going on so
that's confusing you want to listen to
the governor sure okay we have governor
hochul earlier today
and we say no more
no more mass shootings
no more disrupting lives
don't worry creating heartbreak for
people just trying to live their lives
as normal new yorkers
it has to end it ends now
and we are sick and tired of reading
headlines about crime i am committing
the full resources of our state
to fight this surge of crime
this insanity that is seizing our city
because we want to get back to normal
now she's sick and tired yeah so she
waits until a shooting to be sick and
tired good for her totally disconnected
emotionally from the streets of the city
forget about her so then the chief comes
out and and identifies the shooter as a
black male green vest five five heavy
build and the mainstream media goes out
and they omit the race
of the suspect they said oh yeah the
chief described the suspect as wearing a
green vest five-five heavy built it
would help if the media would identify
the suspect so you know who to look for
is he white is he hispanic is he
who cares what he is this is a manhunt
underway for a suspect that just shot a
bunch of people you need to tell the
population what to look out for the
mayor comes out and says if you see
something say something we don't know
what even we're looking for if you don't
tell us what the race of the suspect is
and now it's a 38 or a glock so n asians
are possibly targeted so if you have a
black suspect handgun asians possibly
targeted this story doesn't last for
another 48 hours in the mainstream media
they'll bury it like waukesha judge
i think the i think the governor is
being ridiculous she's gonna it ends now
you know it's not ending until she works
with the legislature to get a law passed
that gives judges the ability to keep
criminals in jail as opposed to the
chaos that's going on on the streets she
sounds like political theater we're
gonna we're gonna give the resources all
our resources look we got the nypd
they're the best police department in a
police agency in the country and you
know her talking about putting an end to
it now it's nothing more than political
posturing can i ask at the end of the
day i agree with jesse on one thing
you've got a mayor mayor adams put on
the damn mask and get out there and i'll
tell you why he's a cop this guy knows
crime and stop wussing around in there
from your house because you may have
covered put the mask on and get out
there and make new yorkers believe that
you're really a cop let me ask you
if they have a photo of the guy or the
suspect because maybe maybe they have it
i'm sure why haven't they released is
that a strategy did not release it they
are not telling you one tenth of what
they said
so that say they know who he is they
would say all right we got this guy who
does he know and they're going to it's a
sister's house they start on the outer
circle on the perimeter they get
everyone who may be connected until
they're ready to go after him and his
immediate circle exactly that's how it
works okay we're going to take a quick
break uh we are waiting for this press
conference authorities will speak to us
on this new york city subway attack we
will take you there as soon as it
happens also up next the biden white
house can't stop blaming vladimir putin
for inflation as another brutal report
comes out hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else